all we need to do is go take a look at
the public health statistics that are
gathered by the states themselves the
states that reformed their cannabis laws
several years ago and to understand the
effects of that reform and if you do
what you find is a very consistent
pattern alcohol sales down binge
drinking down use suicide down domestic
violence down violent crime down
Medicaid reimbursements down opioid
prescriptions down opioid fatalities
down 25% in medical cannabis states
right we know that cannabis can help
soldiers readjust to peacetime we know
that it can help couples work their
disputes out in a more peaceful way
there's this whole body of effects that
cannabis has that I call the overlooked
wellness benefits of cannabis right and
obviously they include things like
epilepsy and Alzheimer's all the grave
illnesses that cannabis can help
ameliorate or even cure right but
there's a whole other body of things
that cannabis can do and I'm thinking
about the way that cannabis can extend
your patience and wake up your sense of
play can spark your creativity can
heighten your appreciation of nature can
teach you ways to resolve disputes more
peacefully right all of these things
that the way that cannabis can deepen
your appreciation of the flavor of a
meal or the sound of music right or the
touch of your lover's skin the way that
cannabis can help a poet find just the
right word or a painter finding just the
right color or a musician finds just the
right note these things are not like
they're not about getting high they're
not about escaping they're not about
getting blotto cannabis is about
enhancing the most valuable and precious
parts of our lives
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are still at the new West Summit which
is the world's largest tech cannabis
conference we are very very blessed to
have Steve DeAngelo joining us on the
show now thanks for having me out and
really pleased to be here man this is
such a pleasure it's an honor you've
been just a huge figure in this industry
leading pioneering so many fronts you
just of cannabis manifesto founder of
steep hill labs founder of Harborside
and now chair emeritus also the star of
weed horse there's just so much to
unpack about your involvement and also
just about the history so will will do
as good of a job as we can in the short
time that we have of doing so I think
that what you what what you were really
teaching me towards you know throughout
the entire conversation we were having
prior to this it's just you know we've
just finished our chat right before we
started this by saying that it's been a
lot of blood sweat and tears to get us
here we can just walk into a dispensary
and get something that can actually help
us with our health and maybe you know
talk about your journey through it some
of your maybe highest peaks and lowest
troughs and just like tell us about just
that feeling sure you know I mean to to
the outside the the development of the
legal cannabis industry can look like
this overnight sensation it just
happened really fast right but it
actually was the result of a multi
generation struggle for social justice
and it goes all the way back to 1964
when Allen Ginsberg formed the first
organization in the united states to
legalize cannabis that organization was
called lamar legalize marijuana back in
64 and and and he didn't get a whole lot
of traction for a while but in 1970 the
National Organization for the Reform of
Marijuana Laws was formed and in 1971
the youth international party the
Yippies which I
apart did the first annual fourth of
July smokin in front of the White House
and through the 1970s we claimed a lot
of territory something like 11 or more
states decriminalized their cannabis
laws in a 1979 Jimmy Carter President
Jimmy Carter endorsed the idea of
nationwide decriminalization of cannabis
right he said famously that the
punishment for a crime should not cause
more high and harm than the crime itself
would cause and so we actually saw a lot
of progress in the 1970s but that
progress was undone in the 1980s when
Ronald Reagan was elected and he and
Nancy Reagan started to just say no
campaign the Dare Campaign we started
seeing all these eggs on TV screens that
were frying and they were supposed to
look like our brains on drugs right so
the 1980s basically saw a rollback
most of those laws that had been passed
the decriminalization laws were reversed
with re criminalization laws and 1980s
really was the most grim time to be a
cannabis activist
it felt like it must have felt to be in
Germany at the dawn of fascism it was
scary it was a scary time and we didn't
make much progress through that decade
until the very end at the very end of
the decade
tragically all we saw the explosion of
the AIDS crisis in San Francisco and and
and it was out of that crucible of
misery and suffering that that we
finally grew the power to tell people
about this plant and start changing
opinions so the AIDS crisis hits and my
friend Dennis Peron Vietnam vet gay man
proud cannabis dealer notices that
people who are consuming cannabis people
with AIDS we're consuming cannabis live
longer and have a higher quality of life
than people who aren't consuming
cannabis and once we realize that once
Dennis realizes that he then dedicates
his life to making sure that those a
patience have the medicine that they
that they need and he did this in very
very public ways got busted multiple
times got shot in the buttocks by cops
which could have hit his spine and
killed him and really just persisted in
doing this 1991 despite being arrested
over and over again for distributing
medical cannabis Dennis became the prime
organizer of proposition P which was the
very first voter initiative to legalize
medical cannabis it was a city of San
Francisco initiative it passed
overwhelmingly in 1991 five years later
Dennis was one of the key organizers to
pass prop 215 which was the statewide
version of prop P and of course it was
it was that passage of medical cannabis
in California that really kicked off the
modern era of cannabis reform in the
cannabis reform movement the the the the
sort of even at the the earliest parts
whenever cannabis was first even
introduced to humanity until now has
been an insane journey and you really
brought us into you know the Carter
Reagan Peron and then now kind of a
landscape oh that was what 40 years of
time about and this is something that
what Wyatt whyever it evolved with us
cannabis and humans there's a deeper
potential story and narrative for why
it's a plant that is so deep Lee
spiritually connecting deeply health
there's so many other benefits and
properties to the textile aspect of it
to that it does seem to have been
restricted look my my friend Jack Herer
another one of the great pioneers said
cannabis can save the world and and when
Jack said that 20 plus years ago it was
just a promise it was just a conjecture
but now we actually have proof that Jack
was right all we need to do is go take a
look at the public
health statistics that are gathered by
the states themselves the states that
reformed their cannabis laws several
years ago and to understand the effects
of that reform and if you do what you
find is a very consistent pattern
alcohol sales down binge drinking down
use suicide down domestic violence down
violent crime down Medicaid
reimbursements down opioid prescriptions
down opioid fatalities down 25% in
medical cannabis states right we know
that cannabis can help soldiers readjust
to peacetime we know that it can help
couples work their disputes out in a
more peaceful way right so since we
understand that cannabis has all of
these amazing benefits on some some
serious social problems right that's
pretty measurable we can measure the
impact on violent crime we can measure
the impact on domestic violence we can
measure the impact on on on on risky
behavior and addiction right it's more
difficult to measure the impact that
cannabis might have on some of our
really some amazing huge social problems
that we're facing right like racism like
warfare like homophobia like sexism like
the fact that our planet is heating up
so fast that we're not going to have a
planet to live on if we don't come to
our senses and do something about it
right so cannabis has the power to to
activate us in all of these ways and and
and if somebody has a better way to pull
us bright if somebody has a better way
to pull us back from the brink of
destruction from killing ourselves with
nuclear weapons or cooking the planet
into a cinder then I'd like them to
bring it to me because I haven't found
anything better than cannabis yet
yeah I really appreciated your list of
ways that cannabis helps humans and that
that needs to be unleashed in its
fullest into our world
whoo right those effects those are like
those are some of the more obvious
effects but there's this whole body of
effects that cannabis has that I call
the overlooked wellness benefits of
cannabis right and obviously they
include things like epilepsy and
Alzheimer's all the grave illnesses that
cannabis can help ameliorate or even
cure right but there's a whole other
body of things that cannabis can do and
I'm thinking about the way that cannabis
can extend your patience and wake up
your sense of play can spark your
creativity can heighten your
appreciation of nature can teach you
ways to resolve disputes more peacefully
right all of these things that the way
that cannabis can deepen your
appreciation of the flavor of a meal or
the Sound of Music right or the touch of
your lover's skin the way that cannabis
can help a poet find just the right word
or a paint you're finding just the right
color or a musician finds just the right
note these things are not like they're
not about getting high they're not about
escaping they're not about getting
blotto cannabis is about enhancing the
most valuable and precious parts of our
lives you are yourself a poet about it I
love it I love it so much
this plant when I was 13 years old man
it's been a love affair ever since then
so and even a moment ago when I pushed
back just the tiny bit on you know well
why is it that then the the certain
dosages of certain cannabinoids can
cause anxiety in people and you said
that it's an educational issue that if
we had a proper education of what
cannabis has how it impacts us at an
individual basis proper research and
science on every single strain that
these types of things wouldn't be
happening
would have a greater depth and insight
into somebody prior to them taking it's
just a whole educational issue and I I
yeah I tend I tend to agree with you
that that's that's that that's true well
I kinda gets you know gets to my book
the cannabis manifesto in the very first
chapter in that book has a statement
that's attached to it the statement is a
cannabis isn't harmful but prohibition
is right and so when you think about
something like anxiety reactions one of
the things that we've been hearing now
is that some people have anxiety
reactions to to cannabis right well I
think that those anxiety reactions are
largely a construction of prohibition
rather than an effect of the plant so in
in in the darkness of prohibition people
were buying untested cannabis they
didn't know what the cannabinoid or
terpene profile was there is no way for
them to understand the dose the dosage
there is no place for them to go for
accurate information about what to
expect from the experience right
now you can walk into a dispensary it's
the cannabis is tested it's labeled with
its its cannabinoid and terpene profile
you can talk to somebody on the other
side of that counter at the dispensary
can give you a good idea of what it is
that you're going to expect right and
under those circumstances you see a lot
less anxiety and panic reactions than
you do in the underground market where
somebody buys something they don't
really know what it is they don't really
know how strong it is they eat one they
don't feel anything for ten or fifteen
minutes so they eat another one then
another ten or fifteen ago they another
one because nobody told them that you
have to wait 45 minutes before you feel
the effect right and of course you have
people having bad reactions under those
circumstances right but if you normalize
it if you give people something that's
clearly labeled if they know what to
expect if they're educated and how to
use it you don't see those problems
again this is that whole they've been
doing it for so long and you're very
aware of how to ameliorate a lot of
these a lot of these issues and how to
potentially guide us into the future of
this
[Music]